max max come here buddy
Oh
hmm
okay can you see me hopefully again
all right oh [ __ ] that boy Rob all right
camera is on awesome all right so what's
up for all the people who are new here
this is our monthly Q&A where i answer
questions that you guys have so yeah
anyway what's up how's everybody doing
today it's a beautiful day like it's
it's uh it's kind of chilly outside it's
like in the mid 40s but it's it's really
nice like I don't know jacket weather my
coffee is right here well at least it
was right here came in the form of
monster energy drink this morning so as
you guys know I usually start or at
least one thing I sort of doing in the
last one and what I'm gonna start doing
going forward is two things one tell you
guys a little story about something that
I have and to to let you guys know
what's going on with the channel so max
give me max come here buddy max up
come here max up up [ __ ] dog never
does what never does what I tell him to
do come on max get up stand up buddy
come here man there we go oh come on no
no no come here
there we go there we go okay finally
match does what I tell him to do damn
dog never listens you never listen to
you max look at that he sees that this
is a milk-bone this is max this is my
buddy buddy this is max max I adopted a
little while ago several months ago and
he's got really bad separation anxiety
and the reason why no we just started a
few minutes ago the reason why max has
separation anxiety is because I didn't
discover until after I had dog
apparently over the course of like a
month he was adopted and returned like
seven times so I was like no no max is
too adorable of a dog to let go so so
yeah definitely definitely adopting or
keeping max here you go max here's your
milk bone is your milk bone back
you wanna you gotta take it max yeah
take it man you gotta take it you gotta
take it there you go
he's like give me that damn bone man let
me play no damn games but uh anyway so
anyway so story time so that's that's
just max somebody in the chat asked for
me to talk about max before we started
this so I figured I'd tell you guys a
little bit about Max he's uh he's a mix
between a Labrador Retriever and a pit
bull and a hound because he puts his
nose to the ground when he sniffs when
he's sending some when he's sniffing
something out so that's that's a hound
he's got the body of a pit bull but he's
got the head like you guys notice what
the ears and the snout of a Labrador
Retriever now story time this is my
favorite camera in the whole wide world
this is a Blackmagic pocket Cinema it's
basically what like indie filmmakers use
and even some professional filmmakers
use I actually got the idea for the
camera from a guy named Philip Bloom who
I highly suggest to check out if you
guys are interested in like camera
videos and stuff like that but but I
also had to go out and get a lens a
macro 4/3 lens which this is 12
millimeters which means it equals out to
about 3035 millimeters roughly but this
is this is one of my hair because it
comes with super high quality the
problem with this lens is that the
f-stop isn't very good so it doesn't
shoot very well and in dark spots so if
those of you guys who are watching the
Rob explains videos that's why this
camera was always so dark because the
lens doesn't lend itself to dark
environments but I liked it I thought it
was pretty cool
so um so questions hey Rob are you going
to make going to look at all-new
all-different Doctor Strange especially
since the movie is coming out yes the
week the movie comes out I will have
both both the story arcs from all-new
all-different Doctor Strange the way of
the weird and last days of magic I think
is what they're called but both of those
videos will be coming out confused where
to start what to start DC or marvel
honestly read both um I'm not I'm not
one of those guys I mean I used to be
like you should only read Marvel you
should only read Marvel but I'm not one
of those guys anymore you know after
getting on with new 52 really and then
jumping in with DC we birth like I
love with DC's putting out right now DC
rebirth is usually pretty
straightforward there are a couple
things like Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern's you just got to read
everything from from Jeff Jones and
that's just the way it is I'll try to
make it like I'm gonna make a video on
how Jordan in the green lantern is the
first story arc and I'll try to add in
what we need to know as we go over it
because really it just focuses on the
Sinestro Corps so we can just focus on
what was going on with Sinestro and
we'll add in whatever we need to talk
about but you know still like I will I
think I'm gonna do a video on that but
you know that like Batman is a
jumping-off jumping-off point like it's
pretty easy to you know to get into DC
rebirth all-new all-different marvel is
a whole different beast it's not all me
when it's not all different when the end
of secret wars happened rereads
recreated the mainstream Marvel Universe
and so basically model just picked up
where they left off and that was much to
the chagrin of people who were looking
for a fresh jumping-off point which is
one of the reasons why a lot of the only
while different mobile titles have
received mixed to poor reviews because
people just don't really like what's
coming out but you know the great thing
about DC rebirth the great thing about
all me Walter for Marvel is it's really
just pick your poison there's so many
different titles out there right now
having said that with Marvel now 2.0
they're changing things up so like the
New Avengers uncanny Avengers and all
new alter all different Avengers are
getting new names and they're being
rebranded and so on and so forth so how
do I feel about Logan I'm really excited
about Logan I think the movie how many
of you guys what do you guys think about
the trailer did you guys like the
trailer or did you guys hate the trailer
because I I loved it I thought it was
amazing Johnny Cash was really cool I'm
not really sure what direction because
it's based loosely on old man Logan and
when I say it's based loosely I mean
it's basically as in like Patrick
Stewart Professor X will be traveling
around with you know Wolverine and
mutants seem to be gone and that's like
it but a lot of us because Fox owned so
little properties from the Marvel
Universe they just don't have enough you
know they don't have enough to be able
to pull it off it's just not enough not
enough content there so they're doing
they're making do with what they have
that being said this is the last Hawn
that we will see Hugh Jackman play
Wolverine and so I have a feeling they
pulled out all the stops and they
basically just kind of let him do his
thing but what they are gonna do I don't
know how many of you guys notice but
x-23 was in the trailer and I can almost
guarantee you what they're gonna do is
they're gonna spin her out into her own
series of Wolverine movies attested the
question is can Fox produce and what
people go see x-men movies that do not
have Hugh Jackman because I think
Michael Fassbender said he's still down
for doing more movies but I think
Jennifer Lawrence is done playing
mystique I think Patrick Stewart's done
playing professor x-max
of course we know Hugh Jackman is done
playing Wolverine so I'm not really sure
what they're gonna do like I don't know
that's this will be the test will do
people care enough about Fox's x-men
properties to go see them even if
Wolverines not there that'll be the
that'll be the test so no I actually
like that he's not half that he doesn't
have a Wolverine costume I like that
he's he's just old and grizzly and that
kind of thing I thought it was pretty
cool yes Batman vs Superman didn't have
a good trailer that's true trailers not
everything but oh yeah Dagan was -
that's right I forgot about that
how do I feel about the Nintendo switch
well I think it'll be cool I think
having a portable device like that is
kind of cool but that's really more of a
topic that I think we would have on
eligible monster more so than then
comest explained but Fox is bad with
their movies seven out of ten times no
foxes foxes you know the guys upstairs
at Fox involve themselves too much in
the movies seven out of ten times so Tom
Hardy can pull off Wolverine the problem
is as Tom Hardy went to pick up
Wolverine honestly if Hugh Jackman's
done playing Wolverine I say they walk
away from Wolfe die thing didn't move
away from him don't have anybody replace
him because if they have anybody
replaced them it's gonna be the classic
example of anybody who tries to play the
joker after Heath Ledger all people are
gonna do is they're gonna go and they're
gonna watch it and they're gonna say
nope he's not as good as Heath Ledger
well that's not that's all that's gonna
happen people are gonna sit and it's
gonna it's gonna cause problems for the
actor you know because Tom Hardy is an
amazing actor but um you know I think
that that if you were to play Wolverine
people would sit down and they would say
he's not he's not as good as Hugh
Jackman Hugh Jackman was the best and
that'll be it so I think the Doctor
Strange movie is gonna be amazing
Wolverine last was how strong its
doomsday doomsday is damn doomsday was
able to hold his own was really able to
fight him to the death against the pre
flashpoint Superman the one you see
right now the Superman you see right now
in DC we breath he was able to hold his
own against that version of Superman and
that version of Superman was stronger
than the new 52 Superman so doomsday
doomsday strong as hell he's one of the
strongest people in the entirety of the
DC Universe oh yeah okay how many of you
all have read infamous I am n the one
where Doctor Doom becomes on them how
many guys have read that
how'd you get back into college some
advice um really just grab whatever you
like from DC rebirth or all-new
all-different well it's really just that
simple like it's not some grandiose
explanation it's really just that simple
grab what you think is uh it's nice
okay
and so in guardians of the galaxy volume
2 from what I can tell they're giving us
a character named her now as soon as I
saw that my thought was it's so good
[ __ ] I loved him from assignment I
thought it was really good we'll come
back to that infamous Iron Man topic you
know Satan as soon as I saw that they
were gonna have the character her thing
guardians of the galaxy - I thought of
Adam warlock and the reason why I
thought Adam warlock is because when he
first appeared he was known as him
that's all he was so we just known as
him the Conclave for the UM side of the
Enclave the ones that made Adam warlock
weren't able to physically see what he
looked like because he put off so much
energy and so what they did is they went
to Alicia masters
the blind girlfriend of Ben Grimm and
they had her sculpt out what it was that
Adam warlock originally looked like
because she didn't have the ability to
see she would be blinded by the light
that he put off but she was such a good
sculpture she could feel his face and
then go from there after that Adam
warlock bought the Fantastic Four escape
the Enclave took off into space and
became the character that we know today
but it would segue it would allow Marvel
to segue into the introduction of Adam
warlock officially that's live I'm just
featuring a cocoon somewhere inside the
collectors collection place but I think
we will see Adam warlock in guardians of
the galaxy -
no the death of X event is not the end
of the accident it doesn't the X event
talks about the death of Cyclops that's
all that does which I will be covering
when that finishes most definitely Sam
Alexander Nova origin and the following
comics oh you're asking me to make the
Sam Alexander origin on the following
college I'll probably do Sam Alexander
and the only water from all the
landscape hmm anyway jumping back to
doom two infamous Ironman I love the
idea of dr. doom being Iron Man I like
what they're doing weather just kind of
like reworking his character and making
him a good guy I love that little aspect
like I think it works I think it works
really really well the question is how
long will this be how long will this
last so that's one of the big problems
what's the next DC character they should
get their own CW show ooh that's a good
one hmm
all right I'll answer this and you guys
answer this what DC character should get
their next should it should get a CW
show what DC characters should get done
if I had my choice I choose Green
Lantern I choose Hal Jordan that would
be my decision but I don't know
so many questions
Mickey Mouse is God well I do a video
about the Reavers yes I will do a video
about the Reavers and Donald Pierce with
enough prep how far can Doctor Doom go
in the DC universe not very far Doctor
Doom has ties to mysticism and sorcery
and while magic is somewhat of a focal
point in the realm of you know Marvel
Comics it's a huge point in the realm of
DC you guys as attentive you have how
many other magic wielders do you have in
DC I mean you got all kinds of different
magic wielders we got the new gods whose
strength is just so extreme that it
doesn't matter whether or not you use
magic they're still probably gonna kick
your ass I mean doom would go doom would
do decent enough on earth but once he
moved beyond earth
you got the lantern course you have the
various races that've been around for
millions of years
I don't think doom would last that long
he's super smart but I don't think you'd
last that long
Deathstroke's okay I have not had a
chance to read Deathstroke rebirth
although I do need to the problem is the
first story arc is like 80 issues or
something on those lines Mixel pedelec
dr. fate hmm I have not read Jason Evans
Ghost Rider as a kid my favorite rebirth
chronic Superman yeah I never thought
I'd say that
I never thought there would be a time
where I sat down and I said my favorite
comic book right now is Superman
Superman is my favorite character but
he's my favorite character because of
what he stands for because of the legacy
that he created but I never thought I'd
sit down and say god man the Superman in
action comics line of stories are
amazing you know I never thought I'd say
that but I am I am saying that because
they are amazing you know they're and
they're incredibly well written right
now uh Kamala Kahn that is how you spell
it
um yes I like Kamala Kahn's character
she's young she's vibrant she's fun you
know she's just really fun to read and I
really like I like her character a lot
and Marvel is it honest you get around
favorite comic book theme shows right
now the flash but that's that's it the
flash is the only good did the best show
for coming by characters on network
television now the best comic books show
in general daredevil season 2 I'd say
the best kind of book related show in
general if I had to go in order
okay what's your old favorite comic book
show right now I'm kind of curious to
what's the best comic book show I
thought it was smile what's the best
kind of look show in your all's mind but
um if I had to go in order I would say
daredevil season 2 the flash daredevil
season 1 Jessica Jones Supergirl
I know that's gonna be a rough one but
the Supergirl right now on CW is amazing
and then probably Luke Cage in an arrow
Luke Cage was good but I'm with Benny I
think it was the weakest of the Netflix
series Mike Colter plays a great Luke
Cage it's just the writing I think was
lackluster I feel like the the writing
could have been a bit better but oh my
god for many answers I'm eating peanuts
iron fist
how good is Thor's a magical ability
okay here's the thing when it comes to
thorne magic guys Thor himself like Odin
son or even Jane Foster
they're not magical the hammer is
magical that's one of the things we ran
over with yeah I'm doing the walking
dead tomorrow that's one of the things
that we ran over with
yeah that's one of the things that we
ran over with a whole idea of the secret
of the untold origin of Thor's hammer
that the hammer itself is magical I had
to think about that for something like
is it the hammer yeah
I'm not I've never even watched preacher
I haven't seen that once I really had no
interested in interest in seeing
preacher what's my opinion on infamous
eye man well we answer that already but
I love it I love infamous Iron Man I
think it's super good Mike I think it's
one of the one of the best all new all
different line of stories out there
right now I ran over Thor I regret
nothing let's see how powerful is Odin
okay guys so Odin has what's called the
odinforce and for something like hell I
don't know 20 or 30 years there was
never an explanation on what the
odinforce was it was just there's the
odinforce and it allows Odin to do cool
stuff and that's it it was later
revealed that the odinforce is basically
the life energy of Odin himself combined
with what was thought to originally be
his two only brothers
envy but it's basically just the source
of oddness power it's his power source
the odinforce is equivalent to the X
gene and the x-men that gives them their
powers it's equivalent to you know the
Terrigen gene or the Terrigen mists
whatever it is it gives the Inhumans
their powers you know that's all it is
you know it's just a source of energy
it's kind of weird that they do that but
it's a source of energy the younglings
I'm having a hard time keeping up all
the questions we're going to slow these
down a bit all right yes I love Suicide
Squad
I thought Suicide Squad was a great
movie I thought it was pretty stellar so
it's the odinforce infinite oh no okay
the odinforce is not infinite how many
of you guys have heard of something
called the odinsleep I'm sure you have I
have not read Tom Kings omega-9
odinforce versus the Speed Force the
odinforce hands down
yeah the chats fly and like it's flying
so fast that's insane I've not read I
hate fairyland Vinny loves it he says
it's amazing but that Alan Scott
yes you have heard of it okay bear with
me on this delay guys yes you have heard
of the odinsleep okay so Odin's power is
not infinite all right think of a thing
of the own source is like a battery all
right when you deplete a battery you
have to recharge it that's what the
odinsleep does the odinsleep allows Odin
to recharge the odinforce the difference
is that the duration of the odinsleep
depends on how much power he uses so
let's say that like Thor was like you
know what I hate you dad I'm gonna take
over Asgard Thor and Odin got into a
fight and Odin defeated Thor the amount
of time it would take for the Odin
asleep to you know to recharge him would
be less than if Odin fought against like
Galactus then it would take more time
for the Odin sleep to recharge after a
Galactus battle then a Thor battle so
that's all that is well fast return to
the weekly pool house isn't it now cuz
he's working on his own project so it's
week we just gave him an open invitation
you know just show up when he can you
know where you want to do so umm I
actually haven't been keeping up with
Deadpool I need to but I haven't keeping
up with Deadpool
my opinion on the superhero movie trend
ooh let's see
well we got an air bubble um I love the
idea of the superhero movie trend I love
what direction they're going with it the
idea of three heroes that we grew up
reading that we know and love all
getting their own movies that is a super
cool thing like that I definitely dig
will Gore come back probably not the
gore was a cool villain battle see him
making a return because the basis behind
his creation is over you know there's no
more need for him anymore because all
the gods have been recreated they're all
back again so Deadpool vs. Wolverine
that battle is as oldest time and it
just depends on the rider let's see do
you I watch as which blade my stream
how was it in the shark
that's weird maybe a freaked out
too much stream gosh
what the heck just happened
okay
that's a problem
hmm
all right
okay are we back are we back are we good
don't feel like we're good now okay
that's weird alright anyway apparently
like it's super behind now which is kind
of strange but uh yeah okay so we're
back um I think we're good alright so I
am back now okay who can rival Matt Jim
Jasper's in DC ooh probably the white
lantern kyle rayner look I know he can
probably do that don't cross the streams
YouTube is always screwed up this
pitiful down anybody who can warp
reality on a unlike a cosmic scale so
kyle rayner green are the white Landry
carburetor could probably do it this
Specter can probably rival him we know
the presence can because the presence is
like God probably any of the
judeo-christian deity so like Lucifer
probably Archangels I mean because I
know the DC is really heavy on
reflecting the Christian belief system
within their own conics or the
judeo-christian beliefs it's within
their own comics so I used to have a
singing voice until I started smoking
cigarettes and then I lost it
let's see do the Spider Woman video yeah
I need to do like the all-new like I'm
okay so so here's your other thing too
since we have so many people here here's
your other thing that we're gonna do too
um alright we are going all right here
uh here check this up oops oh I want to
show you guys my desktop by the way hold
on check this out check out my desktop
that's my new my new wallpaper the red
capes are coming alright um Microsoft
Excel show you guys this real quick oops
here we go all right so you guys should
be able to see this so here is here's
what I'm thinking about doing with the
release schedule is going through over
the next couple weeks I need to fill in
DC or fill in Marvel but see we got
Doctor Strange volumes 1 & 2 I need to
go through here like I think I'm gonna
go through here and just do all the
rebirth number ones the issue with this
is that those videos will not be very
popular just because of the fact that
it's running over stuff people already
know but I'd rather have them and not
need them than need them and not have
them
so dr. Strange's powers so that to me is
it's kind of an important thing like I
want that to be there
like yeah I think it's pretty I think it
is pretty cool
but I want to have that thing I want to
I want to have all those rebirth number
one so for like the next two weeks it'll
probably just be you know DC rebirth and
number one issues like I said you know
cuz it'll be running over I mean it'll
be all the number one issues that have
come out so far so I mean I don't know
you know how receptive people will be to
that oh I love DC rebirth right now but
I just want to make like I just want to
have them for the sake of having them
there and then what that'll also do is
it'll keep me from running out of DC
rebirth contents that's what that'll do
so let's see how does Superman how do
the superhuman act get repealed in the
comics okay yeah okay so so those of you
guys who who kind of who read civil war
but maybe dropped off after that yeah
valiant valiant stuff was coming those
of you guys who yeah so if you dropped
off after or before Civil War came to an
end or you'd simply weren't reading
Marvel during Civil War so we have the
Civil War of and the passage of the
superhuman Registration Act there was a
superhuman team in all 50 states it was
called the fifty state initiative those
superheroes who signed up for the
superhuman Registration Act became part
of the fifty state initiative those
superheroes who didn't were thrown in
prison in prison 42 and the negative
zone now the fifty state initiative was
actually a series of publications that
covered the fallout from the Civil War
leading up to the death of Captain
America after the death of Captain
America there was Secret Invasion then
there was a dark rain I think and siege
okay I keep getting interfered I came
over here was siege or Dark Reign first
it was whatever one during those two
story arcs they repealed the superhuman
Registration Act that was when you
started seeing things like Tony Stark
was removed as director of shield
because the whole Secret Invasion event
took place and all that kind of good
stuff so that's that's what that is but
the value does coming but uh but yeah
that's where all that stuff comes from
ribs and soda commerce and coffee dude
ribs do sound like a good lunch
what above all Iron Man vs Batman they
have they've met before in the comics
I'm pretty sure a favorite superhero my
favorite superhero Superman just because
of the legacy that he created when pool
yeah like I mean like there's all the
all-new all-different marvel stuff all
the all-new all-different marvel stuff
that we have to cover so like I mean
there's like we're gonna cover
everything all the volume what I think
I'm actually gonna do is I'm gonna look
at the solicitations for Marvel now 2.0
and I'm gonna look at what they're
keeping and what they're getting rid of
and I'm just gonna do videos on the
content that they're keeping and
continuing you know like the the
Avengers so on and so forth stuff like
that I'm pretty sure Quinn Poole is
gonna keep going because because to me
it doesn't make any sense to do videos
on content but they're gonna be getting
rid of for Marvel now 2.0 I mean at this
point yeah if we were you know if we
were if I was doing this when the story
arcs first finished I would have just
done them all you know but right now
with all-new all-different model with
all those all those events taking place
definitely like yeah definitely should
have gone through and right now simply
just can't go through everything so how
would I bring mutants x-men to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe through Doctor
Strange literally just have them bring
them in from an alternate reality that's
the how do they just show up through a
portal it's not very original but I
think it would work it would fit within
the context of the MCU but if you could
pick one Marvel character to get a show
or movie that doesn't have one who would
you choose you choose midnight why do
you guys love moon night I don't
understand what people love me tonight
so much I would choose the sentry rail
Reynolds and I'd make it a miniseries it
would be a one-off and it'd only be like
six or seven episodes it would be short
and they would be really well done and
that would be it it would just be like a
miniseries and it would just be like
like the Lego just
all that marvel minis and and that would
be it would just be the Marvel
miniseries it was just like we have
anything on that
so what do you said the new joke are you
talking about Scott Snyder Joker you
talking on the Joker from Batman Beyond
because I love Scott Snyder's Joker so
our God's weaker than the cosmic
entities under normal circumstances yes
their normal circumstances the gods of
the sky fathers whatever it is you want
to call them they are weaker than the
cosmic entities because the cosmic
entities represent aspects of the
universe they're not really physical
beams they can take on physical forms
but they're not really physical beings
so you have a red ultraverse in years
yeah kind of like Aidan Carter exactly
like I would do that so what do you
think of the new Logan Shahada yeah I'd
love the new Logan trailer it was it was
pretty solid like I thought it was
pretty amazing how big is your average
days super busy insane like after I get
done with this I'll have to start
recording a whole bunch of one-shots
probably the one shots for the week for
DC rebirth and then actually here's what
I might do with those one shots for DC
rebirth I might combine two into one
video so it'll just be like you know DC
rebirth one shots and it'll be like aqua
or are we ready to Aquaman it'll be like
Nightwing and somebody else it'll just
it'll just be a series of one shots like
yeah what is called and call that DC
rebirth one shots and we'll put two
characters in one video like that's
that's what we'll do I think because
it'll allow me to get through them at a
relatively good amount of time it'll
still give me plenty of time to spare
for the future story arcs coming up so
what do I think about zendaya has Mary
Jane Watson wolves and I as a beautiful
actress she's a very beautiful woman
and I think she'd make a good Mary Jane
Watson I mean in truth it really all
just comes down to my favorite rebirth
book is Superman right now no I'm sorry
it's Trinity Trinity is amazing how many
of you guys read Trinity number two I
think that you know it all comes down to
acting and I think that that zendaya
will do a great job you know as long as
the writing is good as long as as long
as her ability to act out the character
is good
she'll be fantastic
the question is can't you pull that off
and here's the here's the biggest
question is will spider-man fans be
receptive to her that's the big deal
that's the big one
so what's your favorite rebirth title
besides Superman rebirth thirty two
number two is so good it's insane
Franklin Richards equals the audience
Trinity is to me Trinity it's it's
beautifully written it's beautifully
drawn Francis mana pool it's nothing
short of spectacular you know yeah this
is my job
he's nothing short of spectacular so do
you think vampires and werewolves should
be added to the marvel cinematic
universe including blade yes but that
depends on the success of Doctor Strange
see the issue is that the people have
when we go to when we go see movies on
comic books we have a suspension of
disbelief alright we say yes of course
in the real world you could not have a
guy who's blasted with gamma radiation
and turns into a giant green monster in
real life it would be like the color
book ruins where he's just mutated and
grotesque and all that kind of stuff
that's that's basically how things would
turn out but yeah I feel like Trinity
years of new Justice League but at the
same time people also have a limit to
that suspension of disbelief what you
don't want to do is throw them a ton of
stuff at one time you don't want to be
like hey there's this guy that can
travel dimensions manipulate time he
uses magic he can do pretty much
everything because magic whatever we
don't have to explain anything but while
he's doing that there's also this guy
named werewolf by night and then there's
vampires and blades hunting those
vampires and killing them like you don't
want to throw too much you want to give
people time to absorb and to consider it
part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
which is why I like the the kind of
phasing that they're doing I like
they're they're gradually introducing
things because it's been a while like
the last time that we saw any real
measure of like magic or anything with
regards to you know non normal
circumstances was with Thor that was the
last time we saw that Thor 1 introduced
us to magic and you know science being
converged that's the last time we got
anything unique ever since then it's
been grounded in real world stuff
we get dr. strange which is purely magic
you know and then after that you know
we'll we'll probably get some more stuff
you know infinity infinity someone's
being worked in or a time so I like what
they're doing with that but top three
comic writers Jonathan Hickman Brian
Michael Bendis Geoff Johns
done and done top three riders Jason
Aaron comes in a straw and fourth place
Dragon Ball super is super good right
now
I did not mean to make that joke but it
is it is really good right now
yeah what does my comic collection look
like uh it's shelves of stuff
let's see god I haven't read Earth X in
a long time
Superman is going to race free new 52
Wally West and Titans Izzy that's
awesome that I'm really I'm gonna do a
video on that like he's gonna he's gonna
race pre-new 52
Wally West hell yeah like I'm definitely
gonna do that let's see Reed Hickman
finish before watch your videos or both
ah both you know watch my videos get a
feel for it and then go read it because
there are some things we just we didn't
have time to include like we didn't know
was in depth in the war of the four
cities we didn't go we don't even cover
what happened at Doctor Doom afterwards
by the way Doctor Doom builds an army of
Doom's in the the former citadel of the
Council of reeds
so no Alamo oh yeah they're great riders
but I'm talking about riders right now
like like I mean sure there are like but
even then they've only had a handful of
great stories I mean Frank Miller wrote
you know The Dark Knight Returns in
Batman year one and Watchmen that's like
the three good stories that he wrote
well he also did dear devil to you which
is pretty solid but Alan Moore has like
The Killing Joke has like a good story
so yeah
Boswell is introducing homecoming III
want to see Miles Morales introduced in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe at some
point it doesn't even have to be him
becoming spider-man it's just like he
watches like you see smart a man
fighting a villain or something like
that fighting whoever it is you know and
you see some kid watching
you know and it's dads like miles come
on and that's it that's why you get you
know that would be cool
like there'd be interesting to me just a
nod to Miles Morales so let's see do you
think people are starting to fatigue in
superhero movie genre um I think that to
a degree they are because again it's
just so much coming at them and the
issue is the fact that there's not a lot
of change that's one of the reasons well
I think now was like I think right now
Doctor Strange is the movie and let me
know whether or not you guys agree with
this but I think right now Doctor
Strange is the movie that the comic book
movie genre needs like it needs dr.
strange because Doctor Strange will in
it'll inject a fresh influx of new
concepts you know the great thing about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe right now
is that it's been rooted in realism you
know it's been rooted in you know it's
it's it's really something you could see
if you turned on the news you know some
super soldier running around because of
a serum that enhanced his abilities you
know maybe a god with a hammer showed up
I mean these are things that you could
possibly see you know if you turn on the
news one day which is cool the problem
with that is it makes it so real that it
leaves so little to the imagination with
the Batman vs Superman that was just bad
that was just a bad movie you know the
Man of Steel I enjoyed you know but a
lot of what we're seeing with regards to
the DC cinematic landscape is what we've
already seen you know you sit down you
watch Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight
Dark Knight trilogy I got to throw it
out there right now there's you are
there's never gonna be Batman movies
that are gonna be as good as Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy like no one
will make movies that good and they
shouldn't try they should just make what
they believe to be good Batman movies
and go from there I think that Ben
Affleck will be will do one hell of a
job with that man by the way he was
amazing about my versus Superman it's
just the writing for the movie was
terrible but um you know I think that
with Doctor Strange it'll give us
sorcery it'll give us time travel it'll
give us just crazy out there and
left-field things and I think that's
what people need people need to to not
feel like they're seeing their own world
and comic books and be reminded there's
some crazy [ __ ] that goes on in this
world in this in this cinematic universe
you know because I think that with the
events of Captain America Civil War with
the events of age of Ultron with Kat
America the Winter Soldier with the Iron
Man movie so on and so forth people have
forgotten that Thanos is running around
capturing the Infinity stones
that's one of the reasons why guardians
of the galaxy that's so good because
guardians of the galaxy tickets into
space it showed us stuff that we hadn't
seen before
so I think the Doctor Strange will do
that I think Doctor Strange will give us
a fresh influx and I think that's why
infinity war will be so big it's because
it's going to be the amalgamation of
everything that we've seen up to this
point now here's a big question is
what's Marvel gonna do after Infinity
Ward that's what I want to know because
I feel like they did they've already
done all the best stuff so where do you
go from here I don't know am I happy to
see Richard Ryder back as Nova I mean I
guess I was never that big of a Richard
Rider fan I love Santa Alexander you
know I know a lot of older fans who
liked Richard Ryder want to see him come
back but I feel like Richard Ryder fans
are few and far between I think there's
a lot more Sam Alexander fans and there
are Richard Ryder fans so you know it'll
be cool to see two Nova's there I think
Richard Ryder will reform the Nova Corps
I think that the world mind will come
back and I think Sam Alexander will be
officially inducted into their ranks and
just be the Nova of Earth but you know
the fact remains that I don't know I
don't think there's that many Richard
rider fans out there
danos did it all for the nookie first
came out limp Biskit was awesome back in
the day I would like to see Dormammu
take on the entirety of the Marvel
Universe that would be cool
should you have pizza or lasagna for
dinner lasagna why would you want
anything else why would you think that
the pizzas better than insomnia that's
crazy talk lasagna is amazing which by
the way I need to call give me one
second guys I'm gonna text my sister
because I think she said she was making
lasagna and if she is we got to find out
because if she is I think it was on you
working I'm gonna go over there I'm
gonna take some movies over there we're
gonna use some lasagna and watch some
movies
you still making lasagna there's 11:30
in the morning she might not be up
explain the Nova Corps okay so I did
that I did a Nova Corps series based on
when I was doing Richard Rider the Nova
Corps was more or less Marvel's
equivalent to the Green Lantern Corps
but instead of having like a central
battery core and instead of having
guardians of the universe that created
the Nova Corps and said you had like a
world mind you had literally a sentient
computer program that governed you know
and kept track of the of the Nova Corps
but then you had Nova prime who was the
leader the Nova Corps and the comics was
very different well it was it was not
very different but it was different from
what you guys saw MV and guardians of
the galaxy the pizza is not better than
lasagna saying stuff like that will get
you banned on my channel no I wouldn't
know but um but no like like lasagna is
much better than pizza mega lasagna out
of pizzas that's a genius idea but no he
was very similar basically to DC's
Justice League or DC's Green Lantern
Corps
it's basically what that was so let's
see uh what I like Nova in the MCU I'd
like Sam Alexander in the MCU I would
definitely do that I would love to see
that you were wondering when the
incursions happen in Marvel why didn't
Franklin stop the incursions from
happening okay they tried that um
Jonathan Hickman answered that question
towards the end of the story when all
the thing when basically when when they
were at their breaking point when it's
when they were when they turn to
everything they could possibly do Reed
Richards tried to harness the power of
Franklin to stop the incursions his
ability to warp reality and couldn't
couldn't keep it from happening Hickman
doesn't really tell us why he somebody
says that they just couldn't do it like
Franklin just couldn't stop the
incursions from happening because that
was one of the questions I had is if
well Franklin Richards got these
ridiculous powers why doesn't he stop it
he just his powers wouldn't allow him to
was just it was beyond his ability to
control so um let's see much love from
Australia I appreciate it
Pizza for life hashtag pizza for life I
wanted I want to I want to see that I
want you guys to start talk just type
that in the chat just say hashtag pizza
for life I definitely want to see that I
completely agree with you and I am
extremely happy that Jeff Jeff yeah I
really like the Geoff Johns in control
he's doing a great job cuz Geoff Johns
is a comic book fan you know and he's
it's literally a comic fan running a
comic company or at the very least he
seems to be seems to have creative
control of a comic company and it's
working you know this really seems to be
working so let's see what's my favorite
tantrum in the Marvel Universe
I don't know when Thanos got mad because
death wouldn't love him and then he
turned around and wiped out half a life
in the universe I think that was kind of
cool pizza for life
lasagna see there had to be that one guy
lasagna for life bro
let's see well my the music that we use
in my videos my editor describes was off
epidemic sound so I don't know which
ones he uses well I do more videos on
Myles yeah I'm gonna cover Miles Morales
for all-new all-different marvel
let's see I need the same level
personally I don't know what they're
doing over there if let me scroll back
up because you guys are sitting so many
messages I love John the picnics
fantastic for review the doctor being
one with many others and they should
totally modify that heck with storyline
for movies yes okay I would watch the
hell out of a John not it I wouldn't do
it a movie I do in Netflix like a
Jonathan Hickman fantastic for Netflix
series like I would do I would watch
that that would be amazing but I would
be so hyped for that macaroni and cheese
for life why not both spider-man vs
Cyclops spider-man spider-man by a mile
like definitely BIOS why I would crush
Cyclops it'd be insane
let's see infinity war takes place after
Infinity Gauntlet yes and like
chronologically it's infinity war
Infinity Gauntlet infinity crusade
something like that oh this it's called
the infinity trilogy so miles vs. Winter
Soldier
okay now people are getting into vs.
things what are the Watchmen doing now
we don't know the Watchmen seem to
basically kind of be hanging out in the
DC Universe so we don't really know what
all they have going on right now so
that's that's that's the big
undercurrent that's the big question in
the DC Universe is and what's going on
with dr. Manhattan what does he have to
do with everything that's been unfolding
you know so on and so forth like what's
what's his involvement in this whole DC
Universe rebirth so I think all-new
all-different marvel needs a reboot
no I'm not playing Pokemon go anymore
the numbers for Pokemon go have dropped
off drastically I love you guys no
follow me that or not but it's insane
heat vision versus optic blast well the
oculi blaster what are called concussive
blasts and the difference between
concussive blast and he blasts it's
concussive blasts just impact they just
hit really hard that's all that is being
hit by the optic glass of cyclops and
full you know at full strength is like
being hit by a semi-truck at full speed
probably even more intense than that and
truth because you can cut mountains in
half but it's it's with heat vision it's
quite literally just heat it's just
super hot so let's see wasn't hereo type
of coffee Starbucks house blend that's
my favorite kind all right a couple more
questions guys and then I'm gonna wrap
up this episode um let's see
would you like a Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe movie yes I would love
to see a Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe movie I would love to see that
that'd be hilarious but that's the movie
that you get when Marvel gets all the
rights back that's that's what happens
when Marvel gets the rights back to
everything then you see a Deadpool kill
the Marvel Universe movie cuz I'm gonna
tell you right now if Deadpool stays
popular over the course of however long
it takes your model to get the rights
back let's say it's like 15 years and
Deadpool is still popular like in the in
the movie universe and they released a
movie Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
it would be amazing so good I could be
it'd be pretty stellar but DC does not
need a reboot rebirth is amazing right
now so why is Jubilee not it'll make a
little mutant because she never pushed
her powers to omega-level status those
of you guys who don't know Jubilee is
considered an Omega or potentially an
omega-level mutant because she can
detonate matter on a subatomic scale the
problem is she lost her power steering
house of him and she never got him back
so she never had the chance to explore
the full capacity of what she was able
to do
I love Marvel will ever get the rights
back to be honest but let's see what's
hotter Scarlet Witch or Black Widow
okay I'm not answering that question how
did Jane Foster get to the moon to pick
up the hammer well Jane Foster had
already been inducted into the role of
being a part of the the gods Senate but
God cancel whatever it is where the gods
like I guess the the realms the
representatives from the realms come
together and she was there to represent
Asgard so she already had the ability to
sit in space so she already had access
to that area it's just assumed she'd
just happen to be there so let's see do
I think close saga would work as a movie
nope
I would never go see that that's Captain
America's story edy Brubaker's entire
run of Captain America is pretty stoic
all right guys we're gonna wrap up this
episode of Commerce and coffee I'm glad
you guys came out here I really
appreciate everybody being here again
you know I do this every month so the
next one we do will probably be the week
before the week before Thanksgiving just
because of the fact that the week of
Thanksgiving I'll be busy and then the
week after Thanksgiving on the Christmas
shopping so I won't really have time to
do a whole bunch of that stuff but
anyway guys uh yeah I'm gonna go ahead
and balance off here thanks everybody
for coming out and yeah I will catch you
all later peace